Star Wars the original Star Wars it was
before computers but they really
executed those techniques on a really
clever way all painted
oh no way I thought I saw some ocean
thing there it's nothing to explain how
they did it Ren I'm your biological
father hello there welcome back to
another episode of VFX artists react
today we're going to be talking about
Star Wars the original Star Wars because
those three movies totally redefined
visual effects in the cinema it was
before computers so much of this stuff
is like analog technology that it's
almost mysterious pure magic to most
visual effects arts today so we're gonna
be breaking down how they work I don't
you see that wait have you seen the
original Star Wars I have seen the
original so I'm so excited for this
episode you guys ready he belts on
computers are super important visual
effects but when they made the original
Star Wars the computers they had at the
time what they can pump out was that
little wireframe rendering of the Death
Star that's the limit that's the highest
of computer imaging at the time so all
the crazy compositing and work that you
see all done film no computers only
models in blue screen and compositing
and mattes using actual chemical
processes it's nuts we're gonna explain
how they did it elegant civilized
lightsabers careful with that they
that's a weapon little hidden jump cut
here yeah I wouldn't say it's hidden
it's pretty apparent they were little
skinny it is and the blade practically
disappears so the lightsabers they did a
couple of different effects techniques
and they're doing lightsabers and Star
Wars in the original early Star Wars a
new hope the way they did the lightsaber
so they actually have what have a stick
in a lightsaber right now is covered
with a retro-reflective material
basically the same thing you'd see out
like a safety vest like when you're out
riding your bike late at night so if
they shine a light from near the camera
that stick will basically reflect the
light right back towards camera and it
kind of glows once you had that glowing
stick the other artist needs to take the
film project it onto a big cell sheet
like they use for animation and trace
out a little spot for the lightsaber to
enhance the blade with another little
light pass the thing is there's some
shots where they couldn't have a stick
on set in the lightsaber for example
here where Luke is battling the little
droid but you can really see a jump
around yeah so the artist is literally
guessing as to how long the sword is and
where it sits in the hilt and that's the
reason why and be jiggling up and down
oh yeah source noting this shot has two
other very high-level VFX happening at
the same time there's a little droid
ball flying around which is a
stop-motion element and there's also
stop-motion elements on the chess table
at the same time oh the chess table
isn't this shot
this is probably where the lightsabers
looked best in the whole movie the glow
looks great the actual core white beam
looks good mm-hmm
the fight is so janky yeah if you watch
them the raw footage like the fight
looks so raw
the funny thing is like the lightsabers
are actually kind of fragile there's a
clip from Return of the Jedi
where Luke is going ham on Darth Vader
with just the raw lightsaber and you go
flying up it just broke on him yeah once
I got to later episodes of Star Wars
basically rotoscope artists were doing
the lightsabre effects and its entirety
they weren't relying on a
retro-reflective material on set to give
you a bit of a glow they actually cut
out the lightsaber so that it's just
see-through film for those scenes and
then they actually shine a really bright
light through that little slit to expose
the film itself and that's what you get
with the nice roll off of the glow is
actually double exposing the already
exposed film with something really
bright but talking about how the
lightsabers were made here and how they
actually used exposing film to their
advantage it's how they did a lot of the
breakthrough scenes in Star Wars
so the Death Star trench 1 in a new hope
is kind of like the most amazing
climactic action scene of any film that
decade this is what brought people back
to the movie theatres a dozen times for
all the spaceships they actually made
real physical models and they shot them
against the blue screen that makes sense
you just you know you key out the blue
right but back then it was a complicated
process to actually key out that blue
and that process all begins with how
film reacts to light so when you film
something you have basically three
colors that make up what you see red
green and blue if you put different
filters and from the lens you can see
what your red channel your green channel
and your blue channel are looking like
for a blue screen shot if you just take
that shot through a blue filter on it
and then project that onto
black-and-white film the parts that were
blue will appear white the parts that
weren't blue will appear black once you
have your blue pass that's been printed
to black and white film you can then go
and do just the red Channel now red is
on the opposite side of the spectrum as
blue so anything that had some red
exposure all that will show up in the
red pass and the blue pass so when you
combine the two you take this
black-and-white piece of film and now
you can use this to block light so when
you're projecting things onto a piece of
film to expose that you can now use that
black and white mask to what you expose
one thing in the windows for example or
the background and another thing in the
foreground we're so used to thinking of
things as being stacked to these days in
the computer you have your layers you
can't work that way with film because
once you expose something onto film you
can't just expose something on top of
where you just expose something you'll
get a double exposure and so that's why
you need these black and white pieces of
film because they actually block light
from going through that little mat will
make it so only the part where the X
Wing is is getting light a little X wing
shape to silhouette is blocking any
light from hitting where the X Wing
element was already exposed so it's not
stacked it's actually everything's
basically cut out and having be
perfectly aligned with itself working
with film like this is such a
complicated process because you had to
know exactly how everything was gonna
lie down in the final product before you
even started filming any of that
[Music]
so they film these miniature physical
models against a blue screen but how
they moved these models is what made
this special because they didn't move
the model specifically they moved the
camera using a very special motion
controlled camera rig called the Dykstra
flex using a super rudimentary computer
system basically they would program in
exactly how the camera would move they
were able to do that over and over again
instead of having a ship fly towards
camera or away from camera they would
inverse that process the camera would
pull away from it or move towards it to
simulate a ship moving towards or away
from camera that allowed for not only
the ship's actually move in correlation
to the camera but also to stack multiple
ships next to each other they would only
film one ship at a time but in a shot
like this they are able to have Darth
Vader out in front with two TIE fighters
flying behind him and they were able to
do that because he had the exact same
camera motion over and over and over so
you can actually see the motion blur and
that's actually captured on camera so
they pioneered an idea for Star Wars
called go motion where when the camera
is moving frame by frame by frame along
these shots of the models when it does
the exposure it's actually moving at the
same time to give you motion blur and by
adding motion blur they say that motion
blur was their secret weapon it was
their special sauce that made all this
stuff suddenly look good we did tell you
guys a long long time ago in an episode
far far away that we would do an episode
around classic Star Wars we've got a
couple special episodes coming out very
soon around the Lord of the Rings in The
Hobbit subscribe for that they're
actually coming out for real this time I
am so excited now let's take a look at a
scene that combines all the things we've
been talking about and cranks it up to
[Music]
the thing about a real asteroid belt is
that they're never this is like way too
dense for an actual asteroid belt but it
is what you're gonna see Star Wars is
fantasy not sci-fi look at all these
moving elements yeah a guy getting hit
the hand plate we had a hand-drawn
lightning look at that hand animated
shadow oh yeah that's right all the
shadows were hand-painted and now it's
an actual miniature set as opposed to a
miniature prop so we're flying a camera
through the set and then grabbing the
elements of the ships afterwards dude
that looks so good yeah it does holy cow
it's like there's like 80 different
things going on in all these shots
so there's foreground asteroids which
are individually filmed as you mentioned
actual real physical asteroid props and
there's like a middle layer which is
like all painted asteroids and there's a
background layer and another background
layer where they're doing the same thing
or something just went in painted rocks
and so there then comping all that on
film
[Music]
this shot here in the TIE fighter clips
it's winged remember for every element
you have the color print of it you have
the mat of it you have the inverse map
of it and then of course you have your
background so 25 elements times like
five things needed for each element
[Music]
so one of the last big techniques they
used for this film were matte paintings
it's an old-school technique but they
really executed those techniques on a
really clever way so the scene when the
emperor shows up in return of the jetty
this shot right here
wait those aren't real people that's not
real wait okay so clearly the people
moving or that's real the magic of
something like this is that they're
combining a painting with real footage
where's the seam the front row of
troopers and some of those officers
they're real everybody else is fake they
actually so it's a fake army it's a fake
army in fact they have cutouts so that
the front guys are real but then there's
human shaped silhouettes in the painting
so this is an example how cool it can be
but let's look at a shot that's actually
way more simple in scope but it's
actually clearly illustrates how this
works they're not gonna spend all that
money to make that that set would be
insane you don't need to do that all you
need is a large piece of glass a
talented artist what they're actually
doing is they created a stage and Alec
Guinness is actually just walking along
a platform maybe three or four feet
above the ground and they basically just
painted into the distance
underneath it's and there's a hole in
the glass that is a perfect little
cutout to have the footage be revealed
or projected from behind now the quality
of your matte paintings intelligent
tastes how real things look and it's
worth pointing out that Star Wars has
some of the best matte painting artists
in the world Death Star painted the
trees and then radar dish all painted
that landing platform all painted oh no
way dat is a real model but everything
else around it is painted this shot
except for a little platform all
painting how much does that painting go
for right I don't know I would love to
have that painting this shot all
painting except for the 8080 that's how
they get you is they add people walking
around the side exactly how the emperor
coming down off the platform with a
little droids sliding around all those
things trick your mind and say oh yeah
this is a full thing is this a whole
shebang
before watch hath you guys want to watch
a video the guy and that the mama suit
falling over all like hold up what about
the Yeti he was trying to walk in snow
on two and a half foot stilts with his
mask on he was 11 feet tall he just gave
up on life alright so he explained a
bunch of crazy techniques they've used
so far in Star Wars let's watch it all
come together in an amazing tour de
force of visual effects spectacularity
this video binoculars so what they did
isn't it a stop-motion animation of the
8080 walking and then projected that
onto a film screen and then took a video
camera and recorded the film screen
panning up and down to get the binocular
look Wow alright super cool
the only at 380 80 models the two little
ones in the background are literally
just cardboard cutouts no way but they
match them perfectly the lighting is
exactly the same the perspective is the
same but they're a cardboard cutout the
feet are hidden for where it makes
contact with the ground
oh dude making your job easier because
when it comes to stop-motion you need to
anchor your stop-motion model to the
like the floor to be able to animate it
so trying to show the feet where all the
bolts and pins are it's be a huge pain
this shard here is insane that seriously
looks like a drone racing shot watch
what happens here the camera flies
underneath the legs the 8080 Wow by the
way noticing that 8080 is walking
through the snow and leaving tracks I
just realized that dig goes how did okay
sorry continued the animator has a
trapdoor that he opens and he moves the
8080 and he can't brush or touch any of
the snow around the feet because the
footprints need to be actual real
footprints made by the motions so he has
to be very very careful next the camera
flies under the legs 8080 so what
they're doing is the motion controlled
camera rig okay and then when it gets
close to the 8080 they just they lift it
up and I level up and take the model out
[Music]
I thought I saw some ocean thing there
you saw it the the snow pops into place
like something happened between takes
their pop there it was a big nudge of
snow up on the on the surface that
wasn't there a frame before
[Music]
that explodes all the debris yeah that's
another cool thing about how they do all
the explosions is that they shoot them
in very slow motion because the tiny
little explosion is like this ah done
we're have big explosions like so you're
able to emulate that sort of motion by
filming it really fast to make it
slow-mo
I loved how like those little embers are
going through the air like that well
that's because they actually filmed that
for real going through the air yeah it's
on a cable as a little zip line they're
just recording it against a blue screen
dang that that gave you like the best
looking simulation possible if they just
film that statically you wouldn't have
the atmospherics flying through it yeah
that wind directions correct
oh dude look at that that way that was
definitely stop motion because you can
see the stutter eNOS is the brief
glimpse to the 80s see the chicken
Walker as they called it
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was a great idea to have a whole like
space battle not in space because he
gives you like visuals to see in the
background other than just like a star
field
yeah The Hoff scene is an incredible
demonstration of all this hard work
coming together and really like some
old-school techniques like just basic
Ray Harryhausen style stop-motion but
then combined with like a very inventive
approach to shooting all of it and
combining it with live-action can you
imagine being Mark Hamill and yeah we
filmed this took a while it was hard
work like to do some groundbreaking
stuff hopefully it works and then you
show up to the movie theater and you see
this here's like so as always we ask you
to please leave a comment below if
there's a TV show or movie or even just
a scene that you'd like us to break down
and react to but if you'd like to have
direct control over what we react to the
best way to do that is to support us on
patreon because every patron it's a vote
and one of the things that we'll be
reacting to so that's a way to have
direct access to us and there's a couple
of patrons we would like to thank right
now thank you
Jack O'Connell Bobby Hansel shoutouts
Harris Reggie Patrick Phillip Oxford
we're thinking about you Ellen Oh Martha
not a Canadian spy skanky snack but
Bryan in chosen thank you guys for
supporting us you guys like what we do
here well I consider supporting us
it means the world to us and helps us do
what we do we do have a little bit of
merch left because today and tomorrow
are like literally the last days you can
place an order and still get it by
Christmas this year's core digital
that's I didn't hear you cornered you
told that store corridor digital that
store
[Music]
you